salut c'est heu reux aujourd'hui je vais
vous lire l'histoire
il était une fois un géants de la high
tech qui avait décidé pour son
anniversaire de marquer le coup avec un
produit incroyable pour l'occasion son
nouveau flagship serait doté d'une
encoche en haut de l'écran un écran oled
un magnifique dont anvers se tient au
dos de l'objet un double module photo à
l'arrière horde cette douce façade
arrière positionner à la verticale à la
partie gauche
le créateur a fait le choix de supprimer
son port jack le nom de cette nouvelle
création ne pourraient pas suivre la
numérotation actuelle de ces produits
car elle devait avoir en son nom le
numéro de l'année anniversaire
ainsi cette fameuse marque décida de
sauter un chiffre pour être en accord
parfait avec son anniversaire pour
marquer l'événement ce fabuleux
constructeur décide à même de proposer
une nouvelle technologie à son nouveau
bébé
ainsi lorsque son acquéreur le regardera
le nouveau jouet technologique fera un
scan en trois dimensions de son
propriétaire pour le déverrouiller en un
battement de cils
de plus le mode studio n'avait jamais
été aussi beau des émaux ji animés sont
aussi de la partie
la marque a même décidé de sortir un
modèle est ce pour l'occasion et le
constructeur décide d'appeler son
smartphone stop à votre avis quelle est
la marque dont je parle vous avez cinq
secondes vous marquer sans commentaire
allez-y
j'attends j'attends je vous laisse
marquer les y prenez votre temps à votre
avis de qui est ce que je parle alors d
hémodialyse mais en scannant en trois
dimensions pour déverrouiller une
encoche un doigt envers un double module
photo la verticale un modèle s feu
c'est bon vous y êtes allé au camp la
fin de l'histoire
la marque a même décidé de sortir un
modèle est ce pour l'occasion et le
constructeur décide d'appeler son
smartphone le 1008ha je sais ça peut
être déroutant comme sade effectivement
xiaomi a annoncé la sortie d'un produit
20 de plusieurs produits extrêmement
proche de l'iphone 10 alors pourquoi pas
effectivement il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de constructeurs qui
sont positionnées sur cette fameuse
encoches mais là pour coup c'est
vraiment troublante aimant la
ressemblance extrêmement proches
on parle des huit ans de xiaomi pas des
dix ans
la marque mais pour les 8 ans vous avez
un produit qui s'appelle le 8 alors que
pour l'iphone 10 pour les dix ans vous
avez l'iphone anniversaire là il faut 10
vous avez un design est extrêmement
proche très réussie 2008 l'aixplorer
edition et plus haut de gamme que
l'iphone d'ici quelques mois se sont
écoulés depuis la sortie de l'iphone
disons qu'il ya des choses qui ont été
peaufinées des choses qu'on est
améliorée à voir ce que proposera apple
d'ici très peu de temps maintenant
c'est un produit le chien au mileu 1008
qui est hyper alléchant hyper séduisant
et surtout un tarif beaucoup plus bas
alors on va regarder un petit peu ce
qu'il a dans le ventre sur ces trois
modèles vous avez le 1008 il yal 2008
explorer edition et la nuitée second il
est pas mal d'années différentes ça va
le regarder un petit peu rapidement
alors à dire son centre est déjà sur ce
1008 c'est le successeur du mi6
effectivement comme je disais ya peu une
vie c'est tout simplement parce que j'ai
omis a voulu marquer le coup pour les 8
ans arrivait directement sur le 1008ha
lors le design est vraiment très très
proche pour le coup de l'iphone 10 une
en cochant et un double bogey de la
verticale à l'arrière un dos en verre
avec quatre finitions noir bleu blanc et
or et champagne vous avez un écran super
amoled un écran fabriqué par samsung
faut savoir aussi que sans les fundis
l'écran est fabriqué par samsung
là vous avez un écran de 6,1 pouces une
encoche qui occupe l'écran 88,5 % de la
face avant
c'est du f hd + 2248 par 1080 pixels et
vous avez un ratio de 18 points 7/9
niveau puissance vous avez un qualcomm
snapdragon 845 si giga de ram et il est
proposé en 64 giga de stockage 128 ou
alors 256 la batterie est une 3400
méliand paire eur et au niveau tarif le
modèle si giga de ram + 64 giga de
stockage coûte à peu près en euros 360
euros hors taxes il faut rajouter
activement là dessus les 20 % de tva et
pour un modèle plus puissant ça vous
coûtera 450 euros hors taxes côté photo
vous avez un double module à l'arrière
comme je vous dis à la verticale deux
fois 12 mégapixels avec une ouverture de
f 1.8 ouverture de f 2.4 qui elle me
porterai vous abonner autofocus duel
pixels une détection de scène
tout ça bien évidemment grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle avec emilie
8 10 mais ça on n'a pas gardé si
quelques instants vous avez avoir un
capteur de 5 mégapixels à une ouverture
de f 2.0 un mot
d'ifigha mode portrait logiciels saas
effectivement tout l'intérêt de n 10 qui
va nous permettre avec un seul capteur
de faire un effet bloqué vous avez le
facebook à infrarouge c'est à dire que
le racing bloc va reconnaître votre
image enfin pas de trois dimensions papa
d'un équivalent fayçali au parlement
d'un faisceau locke qui reconnaît votre
image et qui peut reconnaître également
dans le noir avec de l'infrarouge vous
avez un gpl double fréquence pourrait
limiter les interférences qui va réduire
aussi le délai de réponse
donc ça c'est pour le premier modèle je
dirais le modèle de base ensuite vous
avez le modèle qui plus haut de gamme
c'est le 1008 explorer edition alors
suler proche dira lé les grandes
caractéristiques 2008 mais il va
beaucoup plus loin vous avez surtout un
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui est
intégré à l'écran comme ce qu'on peut
retrouver chez vivo le capteur
d'empreintes digitales vous posez votre
doigt sur l'écran dans une zone qui est
définie et là ça va déverrouiller votre
smartphone en plus nous avons une équipe
alors dufeil saïdi c'est un facebook en
trois dimensions c'est vraiment la même
techno crédit c'est à dire que vous avez
un à-pic en trois dimensions de votre
visage avec des points qui sont projetés
ça va le déverrouiller sa très sécurisée
parce que ça va reconnaître votre visage
les reliefs les contours notre visage
vous avez un design qui vraiment
recherché au niveau de l'arrière vous
avez de la transparence et vous voyez
l'intérieur de votre machine faisait
vraiment coûté très sexy ça c'est assez
novateur pour coup et c'est un produit
qui est proposé avec 8 gigas de ram 128
go de stockage et il vous coûtera la
modique somme de 494 euros hors taxes
donc on rajoute 20 % de tva être aux
alentours des 600 euros pour avoir les
mêmes techno de l'iphone 10 pour avoir
plus de puissance plus de ram et un
tarif beaucoup moins élevé et là vous
avez le troisième smartphone c'est le
1008ha ce special edition on retrouve un
peu les dénominations des iphone
l'iphone et saucats smartphones qui est
un peu plus petit vous avez un écran
amoled de 5,88 pouces vous avez instinct
dragonne 710 à l'intérieur un design qui
est sensiblement similaire vous avez
aussi un faith and look à infrarouge là
on parle pas du mapping en trois
dimensions on parle juste d'un faisceau
noc pas un farouche pour déverrouiller à
l'arrière vous avez un double module
caméra 12 mégapixels 5 mégapixels une
caméra à l'avant de 20 mégapixels et ce
produit devrait être disponible aux
alentours des 250 euros hors taxes alors
on sait pas ces produits vont arriver en
france pour l'instant on n'a pas d'info
là dessus chez au mythe arrivé à trèbes
et en france est ce que ces produits
vont
fo ni bhl dans l'hexagone en belgique et
dans tous les pays francophones
bon je serais surpris que ce soit pas le
cas c'est vraiment très clairement le
smartphone le plus haut de gamme de chez
omis il va être disponible dans
l'ensemble du monde là où xiaomi est
actuellement présent on va pouvoir aussi
de retrouver par des revendeurs donc à
mon avis ce produit on pourra la voir
dans nos mains d'ici quelque temps par
ce rêve où dès qu'il sera disponible
je vous en parlerai alors il y d'autres
annonces qui ont été faites il ya la
sortie d'une nouvelle télé cap qui a hdr
uhd 75 pouces il ya un casque vert sans
fil il ya une mode connecté l'ami band 3
dans tout ça ou pas ça peut rapidement
dessus parce que c'est des produits
qu'on va pas retrouver en tout cas tout
de suite directement en france en
belgique et dans l'ensemble des pays
francophones unsa pour l'instant laisse
un petit peu de côté par contre dans ce
cas était aussi intéressante c'est
effectivement leur nouvel obs m et 8 10
c'est un os qui est assez inspiré de ios
on retrouve plein de points similaire il
ya plein de nouveautés y appelle choses
intéressantes on va pas le détailler ici
on bat notamment qu'à une meilleure
gestion du multitâche il ya vraiment
l'intelligence artificielle qui est mise
en avant comme je voulais tout à l'heure
avec un seul module photo vous avoir un
effet boké logiciels peuvent d'ailleurs
pas mal de points d'amélioration par
rapport aux versions précédentes
essayez surcouche qu'on va pouvoir
retrouver sur le 1000 8008 explorer
edition est aussi très probablement le
mieux est ce donc voilà pour ces
nouveautés signées xiaomi mille 8008
export a dit chan 12h08 est ce un casque
vers une télé une nouvelle monde
connecté un nouvel os je suis super
passionnant ce qui est vraiment
intéressant là dessus c'est vraiment se
rendre compte du parti pris de marcher
sur les pas d'apple avec un produit le
plus haut de gamme et c'est là où on va
tout la force d'apple c'est vraiment
d'inspirer tous ses concurrents qui
viennent les uns après les autres
marcher sur les pas d'apple alors pas
tous effectivement samsung continue de
se distinguer avec des produits qui sont
vraiment différents de la même manière
pour sonner qui ont vraiment un adn
particuliers qui ont vraiment leur
propre adn mais on voit que de plus en
plus de constructeurs et notamment
beaucoup de constructeurs chinois qui
s'inspire énormément mais là on parle
même pas de s'inspirer c'est à dire
c'est un iphone like c'est un iphone
like on va pas se mentir mais beaucoup
moins cher sur android et avec des
performances de dingue
dites moi si ça pourrait vous intéresser
ce que vous pourriez tenter par ce 1008
parce 1008 explorer additionne parsemé 8
special edition
dès lors qu'ils arriveront près de chez
vous marquez moi tout son commentaire
parce que
très curieux de savoir ce que vous en
pensez mark et moi tout ça merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo comme
d'habitude je lutte a blessé des jolies
pousse à vous abonner parce qu'on va
parler encore plus de textes j'ai plein
de choses dans les cartons des tiroirs
je vais vous montrer
donc on va se connecter merci à vous et
à très bientôt vous embrasse tous
[Musique]